hey guys hey going as you might be able
to tell I'm not currently in my
classroom I'm not actually even in
Australia right now I'm currently in
Uganda in a set of schools run by
something called the School for Life
Foundation about an hour's drive outside
of Kampala which is the capital city of
Uganda I'm here in the school holidays
because this is a school which has just
been kind of started up by this
Australian NGO it's actually set of
three schools two primary schools and a
secondary because you know in Australia
we kind of take for granted the access
we have to education and that we we kind
of treat it as a bit of a you know it's
a universal human right that in fact we
say it's illegal to not send your
children to school but that's not what
it's like in Africa and certainly in a
place like Uganda right now the region
that I'm in is quite rural so if you
have a look around you or around me
rather you can see I'm in this beautiful
lush land and it's actually you know one
of the things that surprised me about
coming to Uganda is just how incredibly
green it is and how everything just it
just grows and in fact agriculture is
the main industry of Uganda but I'm here
for a week really five days after you
take out travel because it takes about
22 hours to get here in 22 hours to fly
back I'm here to work with these
students and teachers and help them you
know become better at learning and
teaching mathematics which is kind of
the thing that I do everywhere that I go
and it's really been an eye-opening
experience to see the challenges that
children deal with here and it's quite I
mean it despite the fact that it's so
difficult to get to you know many of the
children here they walk to this school
from maybe three or three to five
kilometres away that's kind of a radius
that the school assets so they're waking
up really early in the morning to to
pump water and get get food into their
homes and then to come to school they
start around 7:30 here because it gets
pretty warm in the afternoon
and just the the desire that people have
for education because they see it as the
way outside of out of poverty it's
something that's deeply valued here
which I think this there's not as much
appreciation for when we have such ready
access to schools so it's been a real
delight I am I'm pretty jet-lagged
because there's a 7 hour difference here
but it's been fantastic working with the
teachers and the students and I look
forward to sharing more stuff so you can
learn about the great work that school
fly foundation is doing here
catch you later guys